this is USA I mean it's and blue got is
currently in Grand Final it's currently
the best player here so for link [ __ ]
definitely has every opportunity to
possibly make it all the way back
harvest shin-chan against um second most
consistent player in Soul Calibur six is
history in my personal opinion without a
doubt one of the better players just
that we have at the tournament as well
but yeah so one of the things okay so it
is actually gonna be T reverses Garrow
okay so we was just gonna mention the
possibility of multiple character picks
for both players and then it turned out
it's gonna be both of their their side
characters is all call it despite the
fact that it's kind of like a dual main
for them yeah here we go right on the
chitchat is just weren't comfortable
with two right now but this point here
is very warmed up right he's only played
here this entire topic
wow this is P plus K and it worked
yeah guaranteed damage at that point in
the boat what a stud knew the string 6bb
play this is the first time I'm hearing
to Gerald Japanese voice he's doing like
them well when he does the six PV I just
call the move uh sure is right there
from Shanshan yeah it's got a little bit
of time before it starts up like you saw
there yeah I mean as long as you don't
have to block the first part right yeah
you can interact there's one follow-up
pre damage there oh yeah you know tara
has a lot of those acrobatic options
were all that was guaranteed
unfortunately yeah once she once she
starts to loop and she's going so she
needs to go back to Ringling Brothers my
friends I was not good round number
three I don't know if you're good enough
Cirque de Soleil and that was not the
right clown school anyway
now break attack to try and get the plus
frames right now shun-chan really needs
to be able to push offensive pressure
because he's been on the back foot quite
a bit since that first game
her first rounds jumping over whoa again
he finished it another that's a nice
punish that is minus 12 so that's OAS
although she wasn't gonna get at that
range normally she can do a headbutt
right but the problem is is it short for
sure good block oh stop it in a pressure
that was pretty linear that's the one
weakness of it the 6p be gloomy switch
yeah not only was he in guts it switched
over to gloomy so I got the extra damage
all this stuff what a spoiler I see that
I'm just like oh I don't want to know
the story yet haven't finished the game
he's pushed her at the wall two three be
right things obviously he's not gonna be
able to ring out but the run is up
against the wall he's got about two bars
though it's not that's the first time we
see someone crush that's today he's not
gonna be able to go outside about full
crotch beat me hey Betty's you still
momentum
oh I'm faster that's that's a really
strong clue from Tara right there great
frame great frames on it very quick and
it also knocks down so you get good
finish finish ta a string sole charge to
put the pressure on he is behind so he
needs to make something happen right now
the gas guarantee he saw the command
throw happened in an immediate GI he's
still alive though the sole charge comes
that the yrden gets baited out wait in
New York no more it's yordan it's not
yours
good job - [ __ ] chat that was a lot of
matchup awareness - knowing when it was
okay to attack first just knowing when
it was not okay the patience was superb
it was it was kind of it kind of made up
made or prayed a lot Britta made or
breaking on a lot of the situations
because oh yeah no you run cliff Goodwin
and Mike that Rhonda's over he whipped
like three of them right it was two or
three students who I liked but still
like each time that you take that away
from link that's a huge victory those
are round stealing moves just to think
about using his yard and now on because
fire you know it's like oh hey I can
just use your if I want to but now when
you're getting whipped punished for it
yeah sure it's a bit too far away to
five a punish the block in the mid yeah
hey he's finishing up a lot yeah they're
working well we're punished no
like yet a lot of six six eight K six
six eight charge K yeah I think he's
recognizing that he kind of just needs
to get the the hits here or there he
doesn't need to make anything big happen
because it's putting him in precarious
situations gonna finish it off right
there that was a much stronger round
friendly course feeling a lot more
comfortable I don't know if the stage
switch helped him out just in in
comfortability but whatever the kids may
be like great guitars friends pants off
oh yeah he was looking to block that so
I mean he's gonna be just fine he's a
little bit too far out of range right
now he's tacking on a lot of damage
right there good punish though that's a
whip punish event that thing is super
linear right while standing PP I mean it
has to be super linear because it's
really strong and a lot of other hey be
be so basic for both guys and shits Hank
closing out the round needs it to be
nice and basic you know it doesn't want
to overextend in any way shape or form
but wants to get every damage available
to them and any avenue low as well the
mix-up opportunity for centric really
good for yeah yes the horizontal option
after that you can't just rap for free
switching no okay didn't get it in time
but that's how it fun is 3 P 6 P plus K
follow-up now watch out for the ledge
right here and I mean he's in gloomy now
and he's got a bar but it's it's gonna
be hard to stop the offense I think this
dissonant kind of rod right now oh
that's been so charged
directly after really scary situations
over and over again and sometimes that
patience that normally rewards you can
kind of oh girl you just like that look
at what's damaged in chat so much meter
we get one get the just frame one a okay
mix-up opportunity right there oh nice
duck and he sees that okay look how much
ship damage to he gets from the the 6bv
he still got a lot of proof meter
available to BB oh what a step right
back alright so I was incredibly smart
right there that just like you said
guaranteed and also the most damaging
punish he could do in that situation
drink that water and so one two one now
and remember this is back to two out of
three so whatever happens in this next
game is is crucial
did you see the water mirror mattress
hey you got to stay hydrated bro
sticking out what's here it looks like I
think I mean the matchup has been good
for both players so far staying on the
same stage though so here we go right
into it I'm not really sure how Shin
Chan is supposed to counteract this
simpler style of girl when it's a lot of
a abb throws whip on his three B that's
the general style right I noticed that
the kind of like responding in kind with
her with a with the simple stuff helped
him out in that one round that he won
you might want to try you know lick his
good doing a lot of six six a K and a
lot of six six eight charge Kate he
might just want to try like GI ignite
oh my god oh my oh
there's an interrupt there really course
with the first round and yeah really was
like that how you feel I guess over that
low that's a weapon is cheating wait for
it to finish she just knew that I was
gonna wear big-boy switching over to
gloomy as well not only to get the pig
boy damage but now he's got the better
character as well that's got damage
shin-chan
one apiece right now there's a lot of
bar for Shanshan as well oh wow he's
even I didn't get a second ago so I feel
like a PGI sty chitchat he's gonna turn
it around with you quickly
well the question is how long will he
charge it so that's probably why it's a
little bit of a mix-up so it's hard to
come get all right now into a better
position oh it's nothing
well at least he got something out of
that she weighs coming out the course
it's gnarly waiting out that full charge
again Wow grab the 6p I guess the punish
right there he's gotta through with this
mix up right now blocks the special low
shin-chan to seize one basic hit to
close out smart from Shanshan to you
recognize what he was going for so
instead of doll wanna snap he's really
taking away those six PBS from later
potential match point for shed Chan he's
got two bars to work with for link so I
mean comeback factor does exist one
eight
okay Birgit act very tense when here and
rains here all right yeah you can't
always have Peter iteration good blots
whoa he trying to step a lot of it is
this one idea I can see just that
convert asana line that's it for the
song watch out whoa it's still got some
soul charge available
okay so charge I turn it's exactly what
you were mentioning right there the Soul
Train very nice the final round between
linkage shin-chan USA versus Singapore a
bar a piece right now Shan Shan is gonna
have a little bit more using man you
could all go right now though so I go
for the one a trap applies friends all
day money so he's in gloom amazingly
well played by both players but that
last round so much momentum on link side
you know Shanshan stopped beating the
wake up traps he baited so many of them
in the first two games and and finally
the last game link was it was picking
the right spots to get those chopped I
think one of the things for that is is
the fact that you know link horse was
probably picking it in his head like he
thinks I'm probably not gonna hear it
and because he was already Molly
whopping in a second right so you know
when the pressures aren't like you know
eventually you go back to your old
tricks you know everybody has their old
people out with link definitely the
you're doing